انا من الخرطوم السفيره النرويجي في
السودان وعضو اتروكا اندرو
ستيانسون مرحبا بك سيد اندروس نود ان
نسالك اولا عن دوركم دور الترويكا في هذه
المشاورات وفي المرحله النهائيه من
الاتفاق الايطالي
جوا المملكه المتحده ونحن ندعم الحكومه
السودانيه في محاوله التوصل الى تسويه
مناسبه ملائمه جامعه والان نحن نقوم
بمساعده
المحادثات الجاريه والتي سوف تؤدي الى
استعاده الحكومه المدنيه ونعمل ان يكون
هذا في وقت قريب جدا
لكل هذه الطموحات المتضمنه في هذا الاتفاق
الايطاري سيد اندرو ان تتحقق
ولهذا الاتفاق معارضون من داخل القوى
السياسيه الفاعله في السودان
الموسم
الان هو الاتفاق على المبادئ للاستمرار
بالعمليه الانتقاليه التي ستؤدي الى حكومه
مدنيه هذا سوف يستغرق بعض الوقت للتنفيذ
هذه قضايا مهمه متعلقه بتفكيك النظام
السابق ومعالجه الفساد بالطبع لن يتغير
شيء بين عشيه وضحاها ولكن يمكن ان نبدا
بدايه سيئه بدايه حسنه هناك نعم من يعارض
هذه الاتفاقيه ويعملون في الظل ولكن لا
يحظون بالمصداقيه وان كانوا سينجحون لكنا
راينا بانهم بالفعل كانوا فاعلين اكثر مما
هم الان اذا فهذه العمليه يجب ان تكون
مفتوحه لكل المجموعات لكي ينضم اليها ونحن
نعلم عن مع الاطراف والاحزاب السودانيه
كلها لكي يكون هناك فرصه للجميع ان ينضموا
الى هذه الاتفاقيه عندما يشعرون بان الوقت
مناسب لهم ولكن همم هذه الاتفاقيه ليست
الاولى بين المكون العسكري وقوه مدنيه سبق
ان كانت هناك اتفاقيه ولم توضع موضع
التنفيذ ما هي الضمانات هذه المره لهذا
الاتفاق الايطالي ان يصل الى نهايته وان
همم يعني همم يجذب المزيد من القوى
المدنيه
صحيح ان
التاريخ تاريخ في السودان على مدى عقود
كان قد مر بظروف صعبه ولكن الان هناك
اجماع وليس هناك خيار امامهم سوى الاتفاق
على المبادئ التي تدعو الى بناء دوله
ديمقراطيه والكل الذين تحدثنا اليهم
متفقون على هذه المبادئ
البلاد بحاجه الى تسويه جديده وهي متعلقه
بحكومه مدنيه ونحن نعمل على هذا الاساس
اذا فيما تستمر هذه الجلسات سيكون هناك
جاذبيه للمزيد من الناس ان ينضموا الى هذه
العمليه وهي مثل كره الثلج التي تنمو تنمو
الى ان تصبح كبيره بما يكفي اي ان ياتي
الناس وينضم الى هذه الجهود التي تدعو الى
حكومه مدنيه الامر ليس سهلا ولكن بوجود
الاراده الحسنه والم الحسن من الجميع ووضع
مصلحه البلاد فوق المصالح وقبل المصالح
الشخصيه فهذا الامر سوف يكون يؤدي الى
نجاح اكثر واكثر لكن سيد اندر مشكل
الحكومه المدنيه المفترض الوصول اليها في
نهايه المطاف وما هي ضمانات التي تقفون
على تحقيقها حتى لا يتدخل المجلس العسكري
مره اخرى في هذا المسار
[موسيقى]
الجيش بالامس ادلى بيان قوي بانه سوف يرحل
الى سكناته وسيكون له دور جديد
وهدفه الاساسيه
سوف يكون تامين البلاد والابتعاد عن هذه
الحكومه المدنيه اذا فنحن نؤمن ونعتقده
بانهم سوف بوعدهم فالوضع خطير جدا وهم
يدركون ما يجري في البلاد وهم يرونما يجري
ولذلك سوف يكونون جزء من الجنرال برهان
كان واضحا فيما تم الخوض فيه بالامس ولذلك
هذا هو جوهر
الاتفاق الايطالي لا يمكن لاحد ان يضع
ضمانات ولكن نهايه الامر هذا يعبر عن
التزام الشعب بالسير قدما في هذه
التغييرات والتي بدات بالثوره
وهناك عمليه انتقاليه الان ستؤدي بنا
وتفضي بنا الى عمليه انتخابيه اذا
فهذا الامر يعبر بان الناس لا يريدون
العوده الى نظام استبدادي يريدون العداله
والديمقراطيه وهذا هو يعتبر مكمان هذه
الضمانات المكون
العسكري كان قد يعني همم التزم بالعوده
الى سكنات في حال اتفق المدنيون والقوه
المدنيه في ما بينها على الحكومه وعلى كل
التفاصيل المتعلقه بالمرحله النهائيه
وان يكون الاتفاق اوسع بين هذه القوه وان
لا يقتصر على القوه الموقعه على الاتفاق
الايطالي حاليا وهذه همم تبدو بنظر البعض
نوعا من الشروط غير الواقعيه في المرحله
اللاحقه حتى
فما الضمانه هنا ان يعود الجيش الى سكونات
كما اعلن في بيانه
ان ناخذ الامر بجديه وما يقولونه يجب ان
ناخذه بجديه فهذا ياتي في اطار عمليه
سياسيه واضح لمن يتابع السياسه في السودان
بانه لن يكون هناك اجماع تام
بشان الاعلانات السياسيه والاتفاقيه عندما
تنبثق ولكن نعتقد ان هناك ما يكفي من
الاجماع ولذلك فالناس سوف يتحركون على هذا
الاساس وستقام حكومه مدنيه
والوضعه الان
سنرى فيه عوده لي الجيش الى الثقنات
اراده الشعب بالتالي هي داعم كاف لهذه
العمليه لكي تكون فاعله ولكن عندما يكون
هناك اجماع واسع واغلبيه سوداء تدعم هذه
العمليه فسوف ندركه هذا الامر ونحققه
وسيكون هناك جاهزيه للقول بان هذا الامر
كاف بما يكفي لدعم هذه العمليه لكي يتمكن
السودان في نهايه الامر ان تكون فيه عمليا
انتقاليه مدنيه تجرى فيه عمليتان
انتخابيتان ويكون هناك فيها ايضا حكومه
ديمقراطيه
في السودان
شكرا جزيلا لك